luke siciliano has been a freelance
developer for many years
in this course he will teach you how to
manage your taxes as a freelance
developer this course will be especially
applicable to people living in the
united states
hi my name is luke cisliano i'm a
self-employed web developer i've done a
few articles and videos for free code
camp on various issues related to how
self-employed developers and freelancers
can better manage their business can
make more money can get customers things
of that nature i've decided to expand on
those discussions with this video and a
written article that's going along with
it that written article will be linked
to down below
and the discussion in this video is
going to be one of the topics that might
cause self-employed people more
frustration than anything else and that
is the management of your taxes
obviously if you've worked for yourself
you know taxes can be frustrating to
deal with it can be confusing so the
goal of this video is really going to be
to clear up quite a few things and
hopefully help people keep a little bit
more of what they make now before i get
into what all is going to be covered in
this video the one thing i really want
to stress is that i am not holding
myself out as a licensed tax
professional i am not a licensed tax
professional um no one at free code camp
is holding themselves out as tax
professionals this video should not be
taken as professional tax advice this
everything i might be saying is just
matters of personal opinion and it only
relates to how i do things in my
business
in terms of your own personal situation
you really do need to discuss it with a
cpa or a tax attorney or someone of that
nature you know with that being said i
have been working for myself for quite a
few years and um fortunately i've been
able to get good tax advice along the
way so what i'm going to be just doing
in this video is sharing a little bit of
just personal knowledge personal
opinions and things of that nature so
again if you've worked for yourself
you understand how frustrating it can be
dealing with taxes not just filing your
returns but things you've got to file
file every quarter if not every month
managing withholding
things of that nature
so what we're going to be getting into
in this video is a number of topics
number one we're going to talk about why
taxes matter in other words why you
really need to be mindful of what you're
paying to various governmental entities
and income tax
this taxes tend to be something where a
lot of people just think well they're my
taxes there's nothing i can do about it
i pay what i pay whereas the truth of
the matter is
you can really get ahead financially by
being more mindful of your taxes than
most people are okay so the first thing
we're going to look at is why taxes
matter in the first place the second
thing we're going to look at is some
important concepts to get our get our
arms around before we even really dive
into how to maximize deductions and
things of that nature because
understanding how taxes in the u.s work
on a basic level is important to
understanding how you're going to get
the most out of your various deductions
and how you're going to get the most out
of your opportunities to save some money
on what you send to the government
the third thing we're going to look at
is the fact that how you structure your
business is going to impact how much
you're paying in taxes at both the
federal level the state level the local
level et cetera et cetera so how you
structure your business is actually
going to have a very big impact on your
tax bill at the end of the year
the fourth thing we're going to look at
is maximizing your deductions in other
words making sure that you aren't
missing deductions and as a result over
reporting your income and as a result of
that paying more in taxes than you need
to at the end of the year you'd be
surprised at how many people miss really
important deductions um the fifth thing
we're going to look at is how you can go
about making your payments to the
government during the year because when
you're an employee and you get a w-2 and
you get a paycheck every you know every
week or every two weeks you're used to
your employer holding out your taxes and
managing all that for you well now that
you're self-employed you got to do that
yourself so
it's really important to know how you go
about making your payments during the
year
and the sixth and last thing we're going
to look at is something that a lot of
people don't stop to think of and that
is the fact that where you live
in the united states really impacts how
much you're paying in taxes so let's
take a look at each of these and just
remember that this course is really
meant to
only i shouldn't even say really meant
is
meant to only deal with taxation in the
united states i have no personal
experience paying taxes in other
countries i have no personal knowledge
of or opinions about tax structures in
other countries so this deals with the
us only okay so with all that said let's
get to it and talk about why you should
be mindful of your taxes in the first
place
okay so the first point i want to get
into is the importance of being mindful
of your taxes in the first place
unfortunately quite a few people and
most people for that matter see their
taxes as something they just have to pay
they think there's nothing they can do
about it they think there's nothing they
can do to control how much they're
paying in taxes
and most of those same people also
aren't aware of just what their taxes
mean to their financial standing okay
for most people and i do mean the
overwhelming majority in the united
states
if their taxes aren't their largest bill
during the year they're probably the
second largest bill and for most people
they are the largest bill it's just
unfortunately people don't think of it
in those terms
whenever i have this discussion with
people one way i always challenge
individuals to look at it is to say hey
what are your two biggest expenses and
people will usually list their housing
number one and then for number two you
know they might list a variety of bills
maybe health care premiums maybe a car
payment whatever
but then if you say really do you really
think those are your two base expenses
and they stop to think about it for a
minute they realize they're actually
paying more in taxes than
you know whatever they're paying for
that number two bill or usually they
might even be paying more in taxes than
what they're paying for housing okay so
your taxes really are just a really
large amount of money that you know
you're paying out all the time um during
the course of the year and by by me
mindful of that you can get that tax
bill down
which leaves a lot of money in your
pocket at the end of the year because
it's really important to just be mindful
of the fact that
it's really hard to get ahead if
somebody's just taking a huge chunk
right off the top right
so
really be thinking of how do i get my
tax bill down and that's what we're
going to be getting into a little bit
over the course of this video
by being mindful of your taxes
i really do think you you will find that
you can get ahead financially in this
world a lot faster than
you would otherwise because again as i
said a moment ago it's hard to get ahead
when somebody's uh you know taking a
chunk off the top
but one thing but to be mindful of and i
know i'm going to catch a lot of flack
and might even get some negative
comments over saying this is that a lot
of today's discussion about
income inequality and a lack of
opportunity and things of that nature
kind of misses the point when it comes
to the us tax
code know a lot of people think the tax
code is in in the united states is set
up to favor wealthy people and things of
that nature the u.s tax code is actually
not set up to favor individuals it's set
up to favor activities okay it is set
set up to favor people who run
businesses and who invest all right so
if you're not running your own business
which you know as a freelancer you're
running your own business
but if you're not running a business
which even if it's a solo business and
if you're not investing you're going to
wind up paying a lot more in taxes so by
going the freelance route being mindful
of your taxes and investing you can
really get that tax bill down and you
will just keep a really much larger
proportion of
what it is you're making and as a result
of that you have more money to invest
and then that allows you to get ahead
financially okay
don't fall into the trap of thinking
that
uh worrying about one's taxes is
something that financially comfortable
people do okay
financially comfortable people
don't worry about their taxes because
they're financially comfortable one of
the big reasons they're financially
comfortable is because they worry about
their taxes okay so by engaging in
activities such as working for yourself
and investing which we're going to get
into in this video you can really get
your tax bill down and get yourself in a
better spot all right so be very mindful
of your taxes understand it's one of
your biggest expenses and understand you
have a lot of control over
how much you pay like in taxes you just
need to be mindful of it and it's
something you need to always be thinking
about i mean
if you're watching this video chances
are you think about other expenses you
think of how do i get my housing bill
down how do i get my gas bill down how
do i get any number of bills down start
thinking that same way when it comes to
what you're paying out in taxes
during the course of the year so
with all that being said let's look at
some important concepts that we need to
get our arms around in order to
understand
how you can get your tax bills down
okay so there's a few different concepts
we need to look at to like i said
earlier get our arms around how the tax
system works so we can then understand
how to save money on taxes as a
self-employed developer or a freelancer
of any kind for that matter it doesn't
matter if you're freelance writer uh
freelance developer
uh
freelance you name it
these all these same tax rules are going
to apply so this is relevant to anybody
who's self-employed
so these concepts we need to get our
hands around that a lot of people
may struggle with or just simply be
unaware of is number one understanding
the difference between revenue and
income number two
understanding how an employee is taxed
versus how businesses and business
owners specifically are taxed
number three we need to look at an
explanation of the different kinds of
taxes that we have here in the united
states we have federal taxes state taxes
local taxes and they even those get
broken up into various subsets um also
we need to understand how graduated tax
brackets work and then also we need to
understand the differences between
taxes paid dur for the year and in taxes
paid in during the year which are two
different things so
like i said these are all concepts that
if you ask people about them they may
not really be able to explain it very
well or they just may not be
aware of how they work
so let's take a look at each of these in
turn okay so
in terms of understanding the difference
between one's revenue and one's income
okay
when you work for yourself
revenue is what comes in the door so in
other words
if you're building an app for somebody
um if you're a freelance writer and
you're writing like an ebook for
somebody and they pay you five thousand
dollars to do it
you have made five thousand dollars in
revenue however you have expenses in
running your business okay so let's say
you have five hundred dollars in
expenses a hundred dollars whatever in
expenses and running your business that
revenue
minus those expenses is your profit or
otherwise your income so your income is
not what you bring in it is what you
keep which is uh your revenue minus your
expenses so i'm gonna put up a slide and
as you can see uh my slides are not
exactly a work of art um i also don't in
addition to not holding myself out as a
tax professional i don't hold myself out
um as an artist but under our example
here
if someone brings in again using
uh my example from earlier let's say you
bring in five thousand dollars in
revenue so in other words someone pays
you five thousand dollars to do work
uh during for the month let's say and
then during the month you spend two
hundred dollars
in advertising
you pay out fifty dollars for uh let's
say business insurance let's say you pay
out fifty dollars for software
subscriptions aws maybe a g suite
account things of that sort so in other
words after your revenue and then your
three hundred dollars of expenses your
net income is forty seven hundred
dollars
so what you made was not five thousand
dollars which you made was forty seven
hundred dollars okay
and i talk to self-employed people all
the time that if you ask them what they
make
they actually tell you their revenue
number
as their income not their profit which
if they're reporting their taxes that
way
then they are paying way too much in
taxes because they're paying taxes on
five thousand dollars worth of income
worse versus forty seven hundred dollars
worth of income and you're only actually
required to pay taxes on your income not
your revenue so it's really important
that you understand the difference
between uh revenue
and profit slash net income and that
you're reporting that
correctly okay so remember you pay taxes
on your income not your revenue and it's
important that
you understand uh the difference between
the two
another thing to really understand is
the difference in how you're taxed when
you're an employee versus when you're a
business owner
if you're an employee in the united
states that means you get a w-2 at the
end of the year you get a paycheck every
week every two weeks
and you are the most taxed individual in
the united states okay because
employees in the united states they get
taxed on uh they pay federal income tax
on all their income they pay social
security tax otherwise known as fica and
medicare on essentially um all their
income
and they also pay state and local income
tax on if if that's applicable on
all of their income so when you're an
employee
yeah you're getting a paycheck
and
uh you know your taxes get taken out of
it and you're being taxed on a higher
percentage of your income than people
that work for
work for themselves so
but if you are
getting a paycheck from somebody and
getting a w-2 you are
an employee okay um
now that is being an employee is
different than being a
self-employed person a freelancer slash
business owner because when you're a
freelancer you really are just a
business owner and even if you're only
even if you're the only one
in your business
so
for the purposes of our discussion um in
this course we're really going to look
at uh three different kinds of business
structures that exist in the united
states one is a sole proprietorship
which a lot of um
freelance workers are going to go this
route a sole proprietorship is just at
its sole meaning you know
you haven't gone out and formed an
actual company you're just doing it as
an individual
maybe you got some people working for
you but typically not a sole proprietor
is usually just
themselves um you know and they haven't
formed a separate entity they haven't
formed a business
like they haven't started like a
corporation or an llc or something like
that so the first kind of business form
we're gonna look at is a sole proprietor
and again that's just you have not
started a separate entity okay the
second kind that we're gonna look at is
an llc which is a limited liability
company
as a poll as opposed to a sole
proprietorship an llc is an actual
separate entity an llc can buy property
sell property
has its own bank accounts things of that
nature so if you form an el if you're
working for yourself and you form an llc
then uh you have formed an actual legal
entity that you're doing business
through
uh the third kind of
business structure i want to look at is
what's called an s corporation um i'll
spare you why it's called an s
corporation but
you can actually uh choose to have your
llc taxed as if it were an escort s
corporation you don't have to
form an s corporation you can form an
llc and elect to have that treated as an
s corporation we'll talk that a little
bit later in the video
so for tax purposes
if you're working for yourself chances
are you're either going to be taxed as a
sole proprietorship you're going to be
taxed as uh through an llc or you're
going to be taxed through an s
corporation okay those are the three
main that you're going to be
falling under if you are uh working for
yourself
so
again if you're an employee
you get a paycheck
your employer manages all your
withholdings you're paying taxes on all
of that
if you are working for yourself you're
probably either a sole proprietor an llc
or an llc being taxed as an s
corporation and you actually
get some tax breaks that way by
structuring your business okay
so
understanding in addition to
understanding the difference between uh
revenue and income you need to
understand the difference between being
an employee and being a business owner
okay
um
the third thing we really need to
understand in terms of core concepts is
that there are different levels of
taxation in the united states a lot of
people talk about
their taxes and lump it all into
just kind of one bucket again there are
different levels of taxation in the
united states first the federal
government
is someone you're going to be paying
money to
and you're going to pay that in the form
of federal income tax federal income tax
is what the government uses to run
operations things like
run government offices fund the military
things of that nature so your federal
income tax you pay the federal
government that funds the government on
a day-to-day basis
you also you also pay fica which social
security and medicare tax to the federal
government those specifically go for
funding social security payments to
people and uh funding the medicare
system so those are all taxes you pay
just to the federal government federal
income tax fica and medicare
but then you're also going to be paying
state income tax in some states not
others okay it depends where you live
uh like if you live in uh
california for example you're gonna be
paying income tax to the state some
states don't like nevada don't require
the payment of any state income tax and
in
some states uh if your cell phone there
might be a state income tax but if
you're self-employed there's no state
income tax we'll get into all that in a
little while but for right now
understand that there are different
levels of taxation there's federal
taxation which can be broken off in
several subsets there's state level
taxation
and then you might even also pay local
taxation so if you live in the wrong
place you might be paying federal income
tax you might be paying income taxes
state you live in and then you might be
paying some form of income tax to the
city you live in
on top of that
so the third core concept that we need
to understand
is that the federal tax system works
through what are called graduated
brackets all right you might hear people
all the time say things like oh i'm in
the 22 tax bracket or they'll spit out a
number
and there tends to be a lot of
misunderstanding about what a tax
bracket means
if you were to tell somebody again i'm
just using the numbers to prove a point
if you were telling somebody hey i'm in
the 22 tax bracket that person might
think that means you pay
22 of all of your income to the federal
government okay
but that is not how uh tax brackets work
and for to understand tax brackets i'm
going to put up a different slide
and again here's another one of my ugly
slides
the u.s tax brackets are for the federal
system are graduated and by that i mean
uh
up to a certain point you'll pay a
certain rate and then after that you'll
pay another rate and then after that
you'll pay another rate and so on so
forth so
under my scenario here let's say
somebody's making forty thousand five
hundred and twenty five dollars for the
year in taxable income again their
taxable income is forty thousand
five hundred and twenty five dollars
what you'll see is in the united states
this is for 2021
again the 2021 tax year
you would pay 10 percent
of your first 9 950
in federal income tax
okay any income after nine thousand
nine hundred and fifty dollars would get
taxed at twelve percent so in other
words the twelve percent bracket starts
at nine thousand nine hundred and fifty
one dollars so that nine thousand nine
and 950 first dollar
would have 12 cents taken out of it for
federal income tax okay so in other
words these brackets are graduated so
if you're whenever you hear somebody say
you know i'm in the 22 tax bracket for
exam example that means some of their
income they paid ten percent at some of
their income they paid at a higher
bracket some of their income they paid
at a higher bracket
and it's not really um
it's not accurate to say all their
income was taxed at 22 percent
what it is is that their highest uh
bracket they broke into
was 22 percent of somebody saying
they're in the 22 bracket
this slide is all of the irs tax
brackets for 2021. so you can see your
first 9 950 of taxable income is taxed
at a rate of 10
income between taxable income between
99.50 and 45.25
is taxed at 12 percent
okay
um income between 45 25 and 86 375 is
taxed at 22
and so on and so on and so on so again
as you can see if someone were to tell
you
hey i'm taxed in the 37 bracket
all they're saying is that they had inco
taxable income of over 523 601 dollars
and some of their income was taxed at 37
so understand that tax brackets are
graduated and you pay a portion of your
income at different rates okay
um
but there tends to be a lot of
misunderstanding when it comes to tax
brackets and how that works it's really
important you understand that graduated
structure and that earning a certain
amount
can push you
into a higher bracket and if you keep
your income down you stay at a lower
bracket okay
and keep your income down by capturing
deductions which we'll get into
shortly
um the last core concept that we need to
understand is the difference between
taxes paid for the year and taxes paid
in during the year these are two
different things so
a lot of people
when they get their paycheck from their
employer
and i'm just making up numbers to prove
the point they see that their employer
held uh
you know 500 out of their paycheck for
taxes they think they paid 500 in taxes
what they did is they paid in
500
in taxes for uh towards their annual tax
bill at the end of the year when you
complete your 1040 form
that 1040 form is going to say
here's what you earned
here's what your tax obligation is based
on what you earned
and then it's going to look at what you
paid in during the year which are those
withholdings if you're a w-2 employee
and if you paid in more than your tax
obligation you get a refund back for the
difference if you paid in less
than the tax obligation then you owe the
government the difference okay so paying
in taxes during the year is not paying
your taxes you don't know what you uh
pay in taxes until you do your 1040 at
the end of the year and again what you
what your tax obligation is is then
charged against whatever you paid in
during the year so understanding the
difference between what you're paying in
during the year
and the fact that your tax obligation is
not calculated until the end of the year
is a very important concept
you know for people to understand all
right so
uh now that we've been over
each of those things
uh you'll remember a moment ago we
talked about there are different ways
you can structure your business as i was
saying you can either be a sole
proprietor an llc or you can be taxed as
an s corporation
now
while all those structures have benefits
uh that exceed being a w2 employee there
are different levels of taxation and tax
breaks that can apply to
those different kinds of businesses
so let's take a look at how each of
those different kinds of entities are
taxed okay and understanding how those
entities are taxed can go a long way
towards helping you understand how you
want to structure your
business okay in the last part of our
video we talked about the three kinds of
business structures you can have
generally speaking if you're going to be
a freelance developer freelancer of any
kind and those business structures are
typically going to be either a sole
proprietorship
forming an llc
or forming an llc uh with what's called
an s corporation election okay so in
this part of the video we're going to
look at
the tax benefits and consequences of
each of those and before we do that
though it's important to understand
something called the qualified business
income deduction so the first thing i'm
going to do is explain the qualified
business income deduction which is
commonly referred to as the qbi and then
we're going to look at again the
consequences of
how
of choosing one of those different
business structures and see what kind of
benefits you get on your taxes for that
the first thing to understand in this is
the qualified business income deduction
the qbi came about as part of the 2017
tax cut jobs act
in other words the tax cut law that was
passed in 2017 created the qbi which is
something new to the u.s tax code and
what the qbi does is
it for self-employed people
it makes the first 20
of your business profit
non-taxable generally speaking there are
some exceptions to this but as long as
your total income for the year
from all sources
is less than one hundred and sixty four
thousand nine hundred dollars for twenty
twenty one
you will not pay federal income tax on
the first 20
of any income that is uh related to your
freelance business again generally
speaking okay
so
uh
what how does this work in practice so
to understand this i'm going to go ahead
and put up another one of my ugly slides
i am a better web developer than a slide
maker but again this is just a really
simplified breakdown of
the qualified business income deduction
for someone in 2021.
let's say somebody was a freelance
developer and they had no source of
income other than their freelance
business
they earned a hundred thousand dollars
in revenue you know we talked about
revenue earlier that's the total of what
came into the business
but then the business had expenses on
top of that so let's say you had one
expense that was five thousand dollars
you had another expense that was five
thousand dollars
so
you have net income of ninety thousand
dollars okay
but the thing is while somebody who's
earning a w-2 is going to be looking at
federal income tax on ninety thousand
dollars worth of income
if you're self-employed and you get to
take that qbi deduction
you take the first twenty percent off so
you only pay federal income tax towards
seventy two thousand dollars not towards
the ninety thousand dollars in other in
other words the simplest way to think of
this is that the first twenty percent of
business related income for a freelance
developer gets skipped out of federal
income tax okay which can really go
a long ways
so
the qbi
is going to apply to all levels of
self-employment whether you're a sole
proprietor whether you're running an llc
or whether you're being taxed as ns
corporation okay
so just by running your own business in
general you're going to get a big tax
break over somebody who is working a w-2
job
due to the qbi
so now that we've talked about how the
qbi works let's understand some of the
benefits of and detriments i should say
along with the benefits of these
different business structures
if you're a sole proprietor
you have taken the easiest route for
starting your business okay a sole
proprietor is somebody who is doing
freelance jobs on the side uh on a
continuous basis and getting a 1099 at
the end of the year
and or somebody who has
gotten a general business license and
started a trade name but they haven't
gone out and actually started a company
in other words they just went to the
secretary of state's office and got
their business license started their
trade name
and um you know they're running
everything that way those that is the
easiest way to start up that is the
least expensive way to start up that is
the way to start up that involves the uh
least amount of paperwork okay
um so either the 1099 route or the
actually getting a business license is
what a lot of people are going to do
when you do that
you get to take the qbi on your profit
meaning
uh you know your profit and your
business is your income minus your
expenses and then you're only going to
pay taxes on eighty percent of that
profit that's federal income tax
you will pay self-employment tax which
is the equivalent of medicare and
medicaid
on
uh all of your income okay so under the
scenario i put up a minute ago if
somebody's earning ninety thousand
dollars after their expenses they'll pay
employment taxes on the whole 90 000 in
federal income tax on 72 000 they'll
also be subject to state and local
income tax depending on where they are
so
sole proprietorship
is going to mean
the least amount of hassle and
aggravation getting started you're going
to save on taxes um because of your qbi
and there really aren't going to be any
benefits to it after that okay
if you form an llc
you have formed a separate actual entity
an llc is a legal entity um apart from
its owner okay it's it's a company it
can
buy property and sell property in its
own name things things of that nature
uh it gives you liability protection
there are other benefits that come with
owning an llc
if you do an llc
and
choose to not have it taxed as an
s-corporation
then all the money from the llc on your
te will flow through to you on your tax
return the llc pays no taxes during the
year
so what will happen here is if the llc
has
ninety thousand dollars
in profit
the owner of the llc will then report
ninety thousand dollars of income on
their personal tax return
okay
there are benefits to owning an llc
outside of taxes those benefits include
liability protection uh you know the
ability to bring in partners easily
things of that sort
but for tax purposes
owning the llc
and being a sole proprietor if you're a
freelancer really aren't going to be
that different
you'll get the qbi deduction which again
saves you money over having a w-2 job
but you're also going to pay
self-employment taxes which are the
equivalent of medicare and medicaid
so
tax consequence wise
llc
with no s corp election and sole
proprietor
both better than getting a w2 job
and
uh
you know not not much else other than
that qbi benefit keep in mind with the
llc
you have started an actual company which
means there's more paperwork and hoops
to jump through to maintain that than
just being a sole proprietor
the third step on the spectrum we've
been talking about would be to form an
llc and have it taxed as
as if it were an s corporation
what happens when you do this is
you form an llc the company is an llc
but the irs
kind of just says for tax purposes only
we're going to pretend as if it's an s
corporation
and what happens when you own an s
corporation is you are an employee and
the owner of the business simultaneously
so
as the employee you have to pay yourself
a reasonable salary and i gotta stress
the reasonable part you can't just pay
yourself a dollar you've got to pay
what someone doing the work you do would
reasonably make so if a reasonable
reasonable developer salary sixty
thousand dollars
you need to pay yourself a salary of 60
000
that salary will be taxed like any other
paycheck would for a w-2 employee
because again you've got to pay that
salary through
a payroll service or something of the
sort so you're going to pay taxes on
that just like any employee would
the profits however on top of the salary
in an s corp is where you really start
to see the tax benefits of this because
those profits are subject to the qbi
meaning that the first 20 of those
profits
are not subject to any federal income
tax
those profits are also completely exempt
from self-employment taxes meaning you
will pay
nothing equivalent to social security
medicare medicaid on that
so
no employment taxes
and
only federal income tax on 80
of those profits
so if you have your reasonable salary
and a lot of profits
on top of that
this all this profit
is really tax advantage because you're
paying no social security medicare
medicaid on any of that
and you're only paying federal income
tax on 80 of that
the downsides of an s-corporation is
again you've got to pay yourself a
reasonable salary as an employee meaning
you've got go through all the paperwork
that goes with having an employee
yourself
so we pay a service uh intuit full
service payroll to manage that for us
because we are taxed as an s-corporation
um i'm going to link to uh intuit merch
full-service payroll i should say into
it full service payroll will be linked
to
below um so in other words there's
expense if you're gonna run an s corp
there's expense you have to incur mainly
the payroll service and there's hoops
you have to jump through
uh and you know and and regulations you
have to deal to deal with in running
that
so your income
needs to be high enough
to justify the expense and the
aggravation of running the s corp so
really if you're going to run a sole
proprietorship if you're going to run an
llc
or if you're going to run an s
corporation depends on how much you're
trying to grow your business okay if
you're just doing the occasional project
here and there on the side it might be a
thing where a sole proprietorship is
best for you
if you are engaging a more regular
business
activity and you really want to grow
your business um you know you might need
an llc
if you know and if you're really for
seeing a lot of profits then you know
you might want to do an s corporation
these are all things to talk about with
an accountant just be mindful of the
fact that the higher you go up that
ladder from sole proprietor to llc to s
corp the more potential you have for
business flexibility and tax savings
okay as you work your way up that
uh which one to pick really just depends
on
your particular situation and those are
things you really need to discuss with a
tax professional so
now that we've talked about all that
let's understand what tax deductions are
and look at the importance of making
sure you're taking all your tax
deductions
okay now we're going to talk about the
importance of tax deductions and making
sure that you're maximizing them
again there are a lot of deductions
available for uh small business owners
aka you as a freelancer so in this part
of our video we're going to look at a
understanding exactly what deductions
are and why they're important
then we're going to be looking at
expenses for your business that can be
deducted there are obviously
more common ones that people don't miss
but you are a lot of ones that do get
missed we're going to make sure that
you're not missing those and then the
other thing is we're going to look at
how you can be maximizing
your retirement savings as a form of a
tax deduction and that can greatly
subsidize
your retirement investments okay so
let's take a look at each of these in
turn the first thing to do is to
understand the concept of a deduction in
general and for this i am going to put
our slide back up
on revenue versus income that we talked
about earlier in this video you'll
recall we said that
revenue is everything you bring into
your business so every in other words
this is everything your customer pays
you but your net income is what you
actually pay taxes on you don't pay
taxes on revenue you pay taxes on income
so let's just say for example somebody
brought in five thousand dollars but
then they didn't write off their
expenses of advertising insurance and
software subscriptions that means
they're paying taxes on five thousand
dollars even though they only made forty
seven hundred dollars so they're paying
more taxes than they really should be
paying which means they're donating
money to the government and that's how i
want you to think of it not capturing
legitimate deductions is essentially
donating money to the government and
under our little scenario here
advertising insurance and software
subscriptions are deducted from revenue
that's what a deduction is you are
deducting
something from your business income you
are deducting something from your
taxable income to arrive at the number
that you're actually going to pay taxes
on so a tax deduction
lowers the amount of income
that you are
going to be paying taxes on
so what are deductions it for a business
owner again
there are some that are a lot more
obvious there are some that are less
obvious okay
what you want to do to make sure you're
capturing all your deductions is er on
the side of making sure or i guess i
should say er on the side of thinking
it's deductible
and then let your accountant figure it
out
because if you have an expense here
doesn't matter what the expense is but
you don't tell your accountant about it
your accountant has no way of ever
deducting it off of your taxes right
so what you're better off doing is just
making sure
you put all your expenses in all your
business expenses into your bookkeeping
and let your accountant tell you hey
this is not tax deductible okay you're
better off giving your accountant all
the potential deductions and then
letting your accountant decide what is
and what is a deductible versus you not
giving the accountant all the
information and then potentially missing
a deduction as a result of it and if you
miss that deduction again you pay
extra in taxes
okay so
er on the side of assuming things are
deductible when you're doing your
bookkeeping and putting your expenses in
there and let your accountant straighten
that out
for you this is also
on a quick side note why it's so
important to be doing your bookkeeping
on a regular basis so make sure you're
keeping your book straight because if
your books aren't straight chances are
you are
overstating your income and again paying
too much in taxes
so now that we know what deductions are
and we know the importance of getting
them submitted to your accountant let's
talk about expenses in your business
which can be deducted and for this i'm
going to look at ones that are commonly
deducted in other words most people know
to deduct them but then i'm also going
to look at ones that are
less commonly taken because some people
may not understand that they can take
the deduction
so your common ones are pretty obvious
right if you rent uh any kind of office
or workspace for your business then
you're gonna deduct your office rent if
you pay utilities at that office you can
deduct that you can deduct services you
have to pay for so
if um
you're paying for aws
in your business to host and maintain
stuff for your customers um then that is
an ex that aws expense is something
you're going to
uh deduct out of your revenue when
you're arriving at your income any
services you pay for in your business
are going to be tax deductible um aws
um if you're paying for office software
like google workspace or office 365
would be an easy one software
subscriptions um
uh you know like if you do
if you're a freelance web developer and
you also do a lot of graphics work uh
for your clients um you know like your
subscriptions to
um a service like adobe you know for
adobe photoshop and whatnot is going to
be tax deductible so your services
various services that you're paying for
pretty much always going to be
deductible one with things like rent
utilities uh liability insurance things
like that
those are the pretty easy ones and most
people know to deduct those and they
don't miss those however
there are a lot of common deductions
that are missed in other words
deductions can't that people can be
taken
taking which will lower their taxable
income which will result in them paying
less taxes but they just miss the
deductions they don't know to take them
so
let's look at what a few of those are
and there's a bunch of them but we're
just going to go over a few
one of them is mileage and travel um
under the
tax cut act of 2017 that created the
qualified business income deduction or
qbi that we talked about earlier the
ability of business owners to
write off their mileage got reduced
quite a bit however one thing you can
still do to write off your mileage is if
you are being taxed as an s corporation
which we are in our business
um if you're being taxed as an s
corporation it is possible to write off
any mileage that's work related and you
do this by
having the business which you own
write a check to the employee which is
you
for the for the mileage incurred
that becomes tax deductible to the
business
but because it's a reimbursement the
employee doesn't get taxed on it so in
other words it's deducted on the
business side
and not taxed on the employee side which
means it becomes tax deductible okay and
for 2021
if you're driving for work you can
do that at the rate of 56 cents per mile
now driving to and from your office in
other words your daily commute is not
tax deductible but let's say you got a
drive to a customer's office for
a meeting you gotta drive to best buy to
buy a new computer for work um you know
you need to buy drive to another vendor
somewhere you uh
you know uh you you're driving around
with a customer to show a customer
potential ideas or something like that
though you can write all that mileage
off at the rate of 56 cents a mile so
that's a really important one to take
um
if you're using your personal cell phone
uh for your freelance business you can
write off um a portion of that
uh again you can write off the portion
that is business related is the thing to
understand here so let's say uh 40 of
your personal cell phone use is related
to your business
you can write off 40 of that bill so in
other words if your cell phone is cell
phone bills 100 bucks a month you pay
that personally because it's your
personal phone but 40 of it is business
related uh every month that's 40 a month
you can
write off as a business expense or 480 a
year which would lower your taxable
income by that much so when you're using
personal things like your cell phone for
partial work purposes make sure the
portion of that that's work related is
being deducted
off your taxes
equipment purchases fall into the same
category as cell phones
uh let's say you buy a new laptop and
i'm gonna use some round simple numbers
to prove the point let's say you pay two
thousand dollars for it
let's say
50 of that laptop is used for work of
its time is used for work 50 of it is
used for
uh personal stuff you can write off a
thousand dollars of that cost you may
have to depreciate it but that's an
issue for an account you'll be able to
write off half the cost if half of it is
used for work purposes so that's
something to talk to your accountant
about
uh
travel that is necessary and
non-extravagant
can be deducted okay
so in other words um if you try if your
travel if you are traveling
like taking a trip it doesn't this can
include airfare hotels meals
things of that nature and the primary
purpose of the trip
is for work
and it's not extravagant
you can deduct the work related expenses
with that so in other words
let's say for example i live in ohio
and let's say i've got a
fly to montana to
meet with a customer
the primary purpose of me going is to
meet with the customer it's not i'm not
going to montana for a vacation and oh
i'll meet with the customer while i'm
there the purpose of the trip is to go
to montana
and
meet uh meet with the customer i can
deduct the airfare i can deduct the
hotel
um you know i can deduct my meals things
of that nature now if i do things on
that trip that are purely like personal
entertainment that aspect of it won't be
deductible but the necessary part of it
for the business trip
that can be uh deducted from my taxes
now again it has to be non-extravagant
so for example flying coach might be
deductible
flying first class might not you know
think things of that sort so those are
things to talk to your accountant about
but if you are traveling for work and
it's a necessary work trip that's
something that is uh tax
tax deductible so
mileage and travel through an s corp
deducting uh the business as the
business portion of things like your
cell phone bill deducting uh
the business portion of equipment
purchases of things like laptops things
of that nature and necessary and
non-extravagant travel are just four
examples of deductions that people miss
all the time make sure you're not
missing those uh talk to your accountant
about them and see what you can deduct
those are ways to get your taxable
income down quite a bit if you have
those deductions and
it always does surprise me the extent to
which i see people who miss out on those
deductions
one of the biggest deductions that most
people miss out on is the tax benefits
that come from retirement savings
and
one of the big reasons people miss out
on these deductions is because they
don't save their retirement for their
retirement that's an entirely different
rant
but the one thing to understand
especially if you're a business owner
is that there are provisions in the tax
code
that allow you
to
save for your retirement
you can save a lot on your taxes by
saving on your retirement
or saving for your retirement
which means that those tax benefits
help pay for the contributions you make
to retirement accounts okay
um
the first way to do this is through an
ira which is an individual retirement
account anybody can do that you don't
have to be self-employed
or the second way to do it is through
what's called a simple
um i'm going to look at the ira first
and then we will take a look at the
simple the simple is something you'll do
if you own an s corporation or an llc
being taxed as an s corporation and
you've structured your freelance
business that way so
let's start by looking at another one of
my less than attractive slides
if you have an ira which is an
individual retirement account
and i really recommend a book that i'll
talk about here in a second but let's
say you have an individual retirement
account
for
2020 the 2021 tax year
you could contribute six thousand
dollars to your ira in other words you
could put six thousand dollars into
your personal uh individual retirement
account
that six thousand dollars is tax
deductible meaning if you made a hundred
thousand dollars during the year
and then you
uh
you know uh
made six thousand dollars worth of
retirement contributions you would only
pay taxes on ninety four thousand
dollars
okay
so since your taxable income goes down
the amount in taxes you paid goes down
so what you see here is that if
somebody's in the 22 tax bracket
and they made
six thousand dollars
in ira contributions during 2021
they will reduce their annual tax
obligations by one thousand three
hundred and twenty dollars
meaning that when you subtract the tax
savings
from what they paid into the individual
retirement account
they wound up with four thousand six
hundred and eighty dollars
costs
for
six thousand dollars in
uh retirement savings in other words
they got six thousand dollars in a
retirement account but after you factor
in their tax savings it really only cost
them four thousand six hundred and
eighty dollars
okay and if you keep doing that every
year and that money keeps growing you
really get a huge compounding effect on
that and your tax savings are helping
fund your retirement okay
an even bigger version of this would be
if you start what's called a simple
and i'm putting up the slide for that
now
and what a simple is
is
it's
kind of works it's an ira that works
similarly to a 401k and you can do this
if you're the owner of an s corporation
so as we talked about earlier if you own
an s corporation
you own the company but you're also an
employee of the company
so what happens with a simple is
the individual
which is you the employee
can contribute for twenty twenty one
thirteen thousand dollars into the
retirement plan
the company which you own
can match up to three percent
of the dollar for dollar can match up to
three percent of the employees savings
so you are the employee you're
contributing thirteen thousand dollars
you own the company
which is contributing eighteen hundred
dollars
the individual
where i got eighteen hundred dollars
from it like i said you can do three
percent of
the salary so i'm assuming a sixty
thousand dollar salary here which is
where i get the eighteen hundred dollars
from
so someone making paying themselves a
salary
of sixty thousand dollars before all
their profit
can contribute thirteen thousand dollars
to the retirement plan
which they will deduct from their taxes
keep in mind they have to pay taxes on
the company profits but the company
profits are going to be reduced by
eighteen hundred dollars
so you're saving thirteen thousand
dollars on the personal side and
eighteen hundred dollars on the business
side from your taxes
if you're in the twenty two percent tax
bracket
that's fourteen thousand eight hundred
dollars less
that you're going to report an income
at the 22 tax bracket that means you
save
three thousand one hundred seventy seven
dollars in federal income tax
so
you contributed fourteen thousand eight
hundred dollars to your retirement
accounts
but it really only cost you eleven
thousand six hundred and twenty three
dollars
again you received retirement savings of
fourteen thousand eight hundred dollars
and when you factor in the tax savings
it only cost you eleven thousand six
hundred and twenty three dollars now
imagine if you keep doing that year
after year after year after year
okay and again that is
in contributions from the individual
side where you are the employee and its
contributions from the company side
where you are the company owner and this
assumes the salary of sixty thousand
dollars a year that you're paying
yourself before
the profit that you would also pay taxes
on
so
a simple if you have an llc that is
taxed as an s corp but simple can be
a very powerful way to save on taxes and
be building wealth for yourself
simultaneously okay and being aware of
things like this is how you can really
improve you know your standing
financially
so in terms of deductions understand
that deductions
are subtracted from your revenue or
income to arrive at your taxable income
okay
on the business side of things you get
your obvious ones like office rent
things of that nature that are going to
be deducted before you figure out what
your profit slash business income is
you have your less obvious ones like
reimbursing your mileage through an s
core person or business usage of your
cell phone so on so forth
those can be deducted from the business
also if you do it correctly
also understand that proper retirement
savings can greatly and i do mean
greatly
save you money on taxes
and these are all things what to be
deducting uh retirement planning etc
that you need to sit down and talk with
an accountant for accounting about
because you can really get into some
complicated topics here but the thing to
take from this video is go talk to an
accountant and make sure you're
capturing all these tax savings because
it will really help you get ahead
financially okay so deductions are very
important and make sure you are getting
all the deductions you possibly can and
that's how you keep more of what you
earn all right so
now that we've had that discussion let's
talk about how
self-employed people will make their tax
payments during the year
okay let's talk and i do mean briefly
about
making your tax payments during the year
as a freelance developer
this is something where a lot of
freelance workers and self-employed
people get themselves in a lot of
trouble because when you're an employee
paying your taxes during the year is not
something you have to worry about you
get a paycheck your employer does your
withholding for you and at the end of
the year you've been paying into your
taxes as the year has gone on right well
when you're a self-employed person
it's your responsibility to make sure
those tax payments get remitted to the
irs
and if you fail to
make them properly you're actually going
to get hit penalty at the end of the
year and unfortunately i have had the
unfortunate pleasure of talking to many
self-employed people over the years
who didn't understand how to manage
their tax payments during the year and
now they have a multi-year debt to the
irs that they may never get out of i've
talked to multiple people in that this
kind of sad situation so when you're
working for yourself
understand that you need to be making
your tax payments during the year your
employer is not doing it for you okay
if you are running in uh if you're a
1099 worker
running a sole proprietorship or uh
running an llc without the s corp
election you need to make quarterly
payments um through form 1040es
we're going to link to that in the
description below and that's form 1040es
and there's an instruction sheet
attached to it showing how to calculate
your quarterly payments um
and you can also uh fill out a virtual
form of 1040es by uh directly for the
irs website we'll include a link to that
below as well where you would go to make
those
what are called estimated tax payments
um for a year
the calculation of your estimated tax
payments can get pretty complicated it's
something you need to be talking to an
accountant about the thing to understand
is that
if you don't pay in enough tax during
the year at the end of the year you will
get hit with a penalty okay that is
something you really want to avoid so
talk to an accountant if you're
self-employed and make sure that you are
paying uh an appropriate amount of taxes
during the year
if you are being taxed as an s
corporation in other words you're an llc
and you've chosen to be taxed as an s
corporation which is what we do in our
business
as we've said throughout this video you
own the business but you're also an
employee of the business and you get a
paycheck from the company so we have a
payroll service that manages that for us
in our business
and federal taxes and various taxes get
held out of that paycheck just like they
would uh any other w-2 job
the problem with that however is
you have to pay yourself a reasonable
salary for the s corp but then you have
profits on top of that so i get my
reasonable salary
taxes are only withheld on that salary i
s at the end of the year i still have to
pay taxes
on those profits meaning that i on top
of the taxes that get held out of my
paycheck i still make quarterly payments
to
the irs to cover the taxes that are
going to be
due on business profits
so
um we do it by making uh estimated
payments every quarter some people do
this by
cover the taxes on their uh profits by
having extra money held out of their
paychecks either way is acceptable it's
just important you talk with an
accountant and have a tax plan in place
so that you do not get hit with a big
tax obligation at the end of the year
you know you don't want to find out that
you
weigh underpaid during the year and not
only do you owe the irs a really
substantial amount of money in short
order but now you've also been hit with
a penalty on top of that that is
something you want to avoid so discuss
how much to be paying
with an accountant and understand you do
it either through form 1040 es
or through the irs website
one other thing i'll say on this note
it's something to talk to your
accountant about is i am not a fan of
substantially overpaying taxes during
the year um as we talked about earlier
in this video there's a difference
between what you pay in during the year
and what your taxes are
you pay in taxes during the year think
of that as for example withholdings from
a paycheck at the end of the year you
fill out your 1040 form and it says what
your tax due is
what you paid in during the year from
withholding or estimated tax payments is
offset against your tax obligation if
you paid in more than the obligation you
get a refund if you paid in less than
the obligation
you have a balance due
what this means is that if you are
getting a big tax refund at the end of
the year you way overpaid your taxes
during the year which means for 12
months you've been loaning money to the
government interest-free okay in other
words you've been giving the government
more money than you needed to to pre-pay
your taxes for the year
they're holding that money at the end of
the year they're going to give you back
the balance with no interest on it
as we've been talking about through this
video managing your taxes is one of the
important ways of getting ahead
financially in this world and the last
time i checked loaning p money to people
interest free is not a good way to get
ahead financially
so anytime you come across somebody who
gets excited about getting a big tax
refund it's important to understand what
that person is excited about is that
they've loaned money to government
interest free all year and now they're
just getting the money back i mean to me
that's not something to get excited
about
okay
so
talk to your accountant
again i'm not offering this as personal
financial advice but i'm just saying
talk to your accountant
make sure you're uh
at least paying in
enough to not get hit with penalty at
the end of the year and be mindful of
the fact that it may not necessarily be
a good idea to
loan money to
the government interest free and when
you talk to your accountant you'll come
up with the best vehicle for making sure
your taxes get paid during this year
whether it's through
withholding from
your escort paycheck or whether it is
from making quarterly payments through
form 1040es
which again is for estimated payments
but the bottom line to take from this is
that
one of the things about being a
freelancer is that you don't have the
benefit of your employer just sending in
your taxes for your every paycheck now
it's something you need to be managing
yourself
so make sure you do it correctly and
that's something to talk to an
accountant about and again
quarterly payments or paycheck
withholding if
you are uh an s corp owner okay
so
let's close out this video by talking
about why where you live is so important
okay you have made it to the end of this
video and i know taxes aren't the most
exciting topic in the world to talk
about but they are really important to
getting ahead financially
on that note the whole point of this
video has been about getting ahead
financially and the importance of taxes
in that endeavor okay
where you live
matters a whole lot for
how much you pay in taxes you'll always
hear people say they move somewhere else
because of a cheaper cost of living like
for example i live in ohio because it is
way cheaper than living in a place like
california but what a lot of people
don't
fact tend to factor in is
what they might be paying in taxes if
they live somewhere else before my wife
and i moved to ohio we actually looked
into moving to san francisco
and it wasn't the high rent and
everything that caused us to say we're
not going to move there it was
what i considered to be an outrageous
tax structure in california in san
francisco that kept us from
moving there so
in addition to cost of living your tax
obligation will be
greatly impacted and why is this well
like as we talked about earlier in the
video
there are levels of taxation right you
pay federal income tax you pay
employment tax like uh social security
medicare medicaid but you also pay state
income tax and local income tax well
those things differ depending on where
you are in the united states
some places have high state income tax
some places have no state income tax and
then some places fall in the middle
where
uh maybe there is a state income tax
it's not too high it's not too low and
maybe you pay it and
maybe you don't and some places have
local taxes and some don't
so
in california for example it's a state
that's notorious for having a very high
state income tax so if you live in
california even after you've paid the
federal government all your taxes that
you have to pay to them you have to pay
a big state income taxes state of
california and you're probably going to
pay a local income tax to whatever city
you live in
nevada
is on the other end of that spectrum
nevada has zero state income tax none if
you live in nevada you do not pay state
income tax they also don't have local
income tax okay so you're not paying
those taxes at all in nevada
in ohio
where i live
there is state income tax
but for the most part self-employed
people don't have to pay it the state
credits you back um quite a bit of
uh anything you paid in if you're
self-employed you have to make quite a
bit of money to pay any state income tax
if you are self-employed in the state of
ohio so
that's a so ohio is an example of a
place where
going the freelance route not only saves
you money on your federal income taxes
it saves you quite a bit of money on
your state income taxes you know as well
so
when you're figuring out you know
how to get ahead financially you know a
lot of people do look at hey maybe
moving to another place will help them
because of lower cost of living you also
need to think of tax consequences
in there as well so
again getting ahead financially if
you're thinking of the tax system it's
going to help you quite a bit
and if you're living in a place that
really provides advantages to
self-employed people it makes going the
freelance route
even all that more you know attractive
so the one thing i would hope that you
really take from this video is that a
proper tax planning can really help you
get ahead
a lot of people fail to consider the
fact that their taxes if they're not
their biggest expense or their second
biggest expense and for most people they
are the biggest expense okay you cannot
get ahead financially unless you're
getting your taxes under control it is
just very very hard to do remember
people who are well off tend to be well
off in part because they
think about their taxes
i know this video as long as it was
really only touched a lot of these
topics on like a very
surface kind of level it's because taxes
can get very complicated so that is why
it's really important that you discuss
these things with a professional if you
are
going to freelance route the
self-employment route and you are
working hard at it and making good money
at it
it is well worth the cost of a good
accountant to make sure you are saving
on your taxes so i hope you found this
video helpful um if there are any topics
you'd like to see discussed in the
future please drop them in the comments
section below and make sure you support
free code camp all right thank you